OK, let's get into it.
Donald Trump in a continued effort to show
us how great he's doing, how healthy he is,
has put out another video in which he calls
Catching Covered a blessing from God.
But the real worthiness of the news video
is that Donald Trump looks terrible.
He sounds terrible.
He doesn't even seem to know what day it is
or how long he was in the hospital.
So let's look at it.
This is nearly a five minute video.
We're not going to look at all of it.
But the first thing you notice as we just
play some video without audio for our audience
that's watching is that Donald Trump's face
looks completely bruised and they think that
what they did is deliberately put him under
a tree so that there's a shadow on his face
from the branches.
But that's not all that's going on.
In other words, his right cheek seems bruised.
His right eye is almost completely swollen
shut.
For most of the video.
His lips seem like the only thing on his face
that don't have makeup, and they are absolutely
white as a ghost.
It's an image of a man not doing particularly
well, despite claiming now for days that Trump
has had no symptoms.
But when you start listening to what Trump
says, you can't help but notice that Donald
Trump is cotton mouth.
Short of breath and slurring even more than
his usual for him.
Let's look at the first clip.
Perhaps you recognize me.
It's your favorite president.
And I'm standing in front of the Oval Office
at the White House, which is always an exciting
place to be.
I got back a day ago from Walter Reed Medical
Center who spent four days there.
So it's already very strange because Trump
says, I got back a day ago.
Well, when this was released yesterday, Trump
had already been back at the White House for
two days.
Is now maybe the explanation is simple, maybe
they they filmed it Tuesday, but published
it Wednesday.
But then Donald Trump says he spent four days
at Walter Reed.
He didn't.
Trump spent about 54 hours at Walter Reed.
He didn't spend four days there.
He didn't even spend parts of four days there.
So, again, it's raising questions of is Trump
okay?
How connected to reality is Donald Trump?
This continues.
We'll skip ahead a little bit and then you'll
start to notice Donald Trump sounding hoarse
and struggling to breathe again.
Well, I spent four days there and I went and
I wasn't feeling so hot.
And within a very short period of time, they
gave me Regeneron.
It's called Regeneron and other things, too.
But I think this was the key.
But they gave me Regeneron and it was like,
unbelievable.
I felt good.
Immediately I felt as good.
Three days ago as I do now.
So I just want to say we have Regeneron.
We have a very similar drug from Eli Lilly,
and they are coming out and we're trying to
get them on an emergency basis.
We've authorized it.
I've authorized it.
And if you're in the hospital and you're feeling
really bad, I think we're going to work it
so that you get them in, you're going to get
them free.
And especially if you're a senior, we're going
to get you in there quick.
So this is interesting because as of this
recording, somewhere between 10 and 25 people
total in the entire country had received this
antibody cocktail from Regeneron.
Trump says he's going to give it for free
to every senior in the hospital, maybe to
everybody even now.
Maybe that's a nice idea.
Remember, this is an unapproved antibody cocktail
as of yet.
But how do you get something that's been given
to only 10 or 25 people total?
How do you get that to every senior in the
hospital with Corona virus for free?
In any case, he says that there's many doses
coming online.
It's an interesting idea, but it doesn't seem
to connect with reality.
We continue.
Donald Trump briefly says vaccines are coming
soon.
I won't be playing that since it's the same
thing he's been saying on vaccines for a while.
But then he gets into this.
Getting covered was a blessing from God stuff.
And that's what I want for everybody.
I want everybody to be given the same treatment
as your president, because I feel great.
I feel like perfect.
So I think this was a blessing from God that
I caught it.
This was a blessing in disguise.
I heard about this drug.
I said, let me take it.
It was my suggestion.
And it was incredible the way it worked.
Incredible.
So when Trump says that he feels perfect,
that's, of course, really tough to believe
when he's slurring with cotton mouth, looking
bruised with his right eye swollen shut and
struggling to breathe.
But this idea that now that Trump has gotten
the virus, he's over some hump and now he
can really start dealing with it.
It is an insult to everyone who didn't have
the care that Donald Trump got in his six
room suite at Walter Reed.
It's an insult to everybody who died merely
because I guess up until now, Trump didn't
really get it.
And who had family members die and the entire
thing.
And as always, it's a what's the phrase a
day late and a dollar short?
This is more than that.
This is seven months late and 250000 deaths
too late.
And we continue to be very skeptical that
Donald Trump is actually healthy.
And to be very clear that the speculation
that Donald Trump is not doing so well.
It's not about making fun of people who have
corona virus.
It's not about anything other than they lie
about everything.
And the hypocrisy of saying Hillary had Parkinson's.
And Biden has dementia while obviously lying
about the health of Donald Trump.
The hypocrisy knows no bounds.
And we're going to have more about this on
the David Pakman show, Instagram page, which
I hope you're following at David Pakman show
on Instagram.
And we'll just have to see what Trump looks
like by tomorrow.
Again, seemingly bailed out on the debate
because he doesn't want to do it remote.
But we'll talk about that a
little bit later
in today's program.